so who who has who have you interviewed
that's been most popular
noam chomsky
and you're
you're
you're one of the reasons why because i
was the first person if not the only
person to ask him about you directly
oh
so i don't know about that so there's
something we could talk about right away
so what did he have to say
well essentially you're hitler
you haven't talked much about jordan
peterson and i wanted to know if you had
any disagreements with
what he says
frankly i pay very little attention but
if you want to know about jordan peters
and i think the best thing i can refer
you to is an
article by uh nathan
robinson very
sharp acute critic in his journal
current affairs
it's called something like
the intellectual we deserve or something
like that i think that that's basically
my answer other than that i don't pay
any attention
i mean there's some issues on which i
probably agree with hitler no it doesn't
mean much
so as you know oh yeah
yeah yeah and that and so why do you
think he thinks that
i think that people who are on a certain
side on the political spectrum believe
their side
stands for what's good and the opposite
side is what's not good one of the see
that's so tricky man talking about
better left instead which we'll get to
later is how do you define the left and
the right it's decidedly difficult
almost everyone has a different
definition
chomsky would say well the left is
freedom and so anything that's on the
right is anti-freedom and the right
people who are on the right or identify
with being as such would
perhaps categorize it as the opposite
yeah well it's interesting at least that
they might circle around claims to some
uh let's say virtue that both of them
would admire like freedom
right so there's some agreement there
despite the different difference did he
point to anything particular about what
i hypothetically thought that made me
not
an acceptable sort of creature
no
it's somewhat it's somewhat hearsay in
the sense that he read an article based
on you so he didn't watch you directly
he read nathan robinson's critique of
you which i'm sure oh yeah well that'll
do it man
yeah yeah old nathan he's he's quite the
character yeah i see so
well that's too bad in many regards
did you learn anything in particular
from talking to
dr chomsky
quite a significant amount as for what i
can point to let me think i spoke to him
six times
six times on the channel so the first
time about you i found it interesting
that he said
i asked each guest that i spoke to at
the time because now i've pivoted away
from politics for a reason for reasons
we can get to later i asked him
and every other guest when does the left
go too far in some sense it's a
petersonian question because you've
raised that quite a few times
when does the left go too far he said
well it's not a matter of going too far
for the left it's a matter of tactics as
for when does the right go too far so
while the right is
suicidal i think was his words
so that's that's interesting because
it's really not much of an answer i mean
i've been always looking for a technical
definition of that right it's like well
we know the right can go too far and we
know the left can go too far and
how do we point to and i think this
problem has actually become more
complicated rather than less because the
more i've been thinking about it the
more i think that
the errors on the left are
more in the nature of a vast number of
small errors mostly of
often of omission so the more
reasonable people on the left
kowtow too rapidly to the more radical
types on the left especially at the
philosophical level and i think that
really happened at the universities
so
one that's a one like that's something
we can explore well it's actually a
question i would have for you why do you
think that is i know that this is mainly
you interviewing me but i'm still
perplexed when it comes to that why is
it that the center left doesn't
excoriate the extreme lift is it because
they're on the same side so the enemy of
my enemy is my friend or are they afraid
because
well they can get
you can lose even a tenured position